[Music]
hello everyone we are here at San Diego
comic-con at 2019 and right now we've
got a Collider exclusive interview for
you with the folks behind emergence on
ABC I have to say another
congratulations to you guys because I
like the pilot quite a bit I'd love to
start with you too because I'm curious
about the idea that started this all
what was the specific thing that kicked
it off was it the bigger sci-fi picture
or maybe a specific character arc I
think it was we always like doing shows
that it's our world but there's one
magic thing in the world so there's our
world but there's a also a portal to
John Malkovich's head so I think that
all that always sort of is where we
start do you remember you know also we
were we do a whole process where we try
to find things that speak to us and we
were talking about movies of our youth
and Spielberg and you know just kind of
encounters yeah and one things that were
a little scary but at the same time kind
of talked to about a family that's why
it clicked so well for me those are the
perfect names and movies I'm also a
little curious about your process with
the the pickup situation too I mean was
that just a big emotional whirlwind for
you where it's like hang out and all of
a sudden it was insane it was the best
day we're happy and then things got
quiet and we've done this enough where
it's like well maybe they're just not
gonna pick it up and we'll just do
something else and you just you you sort
of learns like don't get too invested
don't get too excited and then we got a
call from the studio saying ABC network
is asking us questions can you go in
tonight and pitch them the show and so
there's about four hours later we're
pitching the show to the new president
of ABC
and two days later it was on a Saturday
we were at my daughter's first communion
in church and we're getting calls and
I'm like I can't talk to you I'm just
sending it to voicemail but it was so we
got the pickup like but it was us when
those things having to tell everyone
you're gonna see NBC schedule come out
don't panic yes and it was just like
just hold on I like to think I gir
actually saw the pilot and was like yo
emergence we need it that's how I look
at things I believe that because you
said it I think I think that is what
happened actually also curious just from
the pitching perspective now with the
landscape changing do you have to go
into just about every show you put
together at this point thinking oh like
this could work as a serialized Network
show but if you want it could also work
on a streaming platform too you know
what I still we like to do something
we're interested in and hopefully it
finds a home it's too hard to try and
like craft it for one specific thing or
another just like here's what works you
either like that or you don't like that
and because you really can't sort of
predict what people are going to like
because it changes every single year we
thought we were writing an NBC show yeah
it's on ABC I'm glad it landed there
Donald you've obviously had a ton of
success on TV so I was wondering has
what you looked for in a show to sign on
for changed at all from way back then
when you first started to what you look
for now well yeah absolutely you know I
started out as just an actor and
somewhere along the line I've developed
in a neat with comedy and so when
emergence came around it was the one
pilot that was on the plate on the table
for me that wasn't a comedy and I was
like that's the one I want to go for it
that's the one I want to try and do and
I went in I remember auditioning and
after the aw did after the audition I
remember going to my kids soccer
practice and being like to my wife babe
you know I went in I don't think they're
gonna give it to me I'm gonna be honest
with you I think I walked in and they
were like Turk you know and then they
called an ad and and and it happened and
it was found a walks in and you have an
idea of what you think Donald is if
you've never met him it's like okay I
know who this is and was and probably
not gonna work with sure let's see and
by I'm he by the time he walked out of
the room we were like kid oh he just got
that heart like it was it was you knew
right away it was for we all turned to
each other we're like I didn't want to
tell that was it Sabrina I'm wondering
if it's the exact opposite for you
because I know you were on New Amsterdam
so it was it just like sidestepping over
to a doctor role here well I wasn't a
thank you I wasn't a doctor on my demos
administrative side of the hospital and
it was a weird though to book a role
playing a pediatrician and the scene
that I had in the pilot in the hospital
it was odd she had called and said hey
you want to get drinks cuz we've worked
together before and Michelle and I
looked at each other and said Oh Sabrina
how all good things starts do you want
to get drinks do you want to paly while
we're getting drinks is knowing it a lot
of drinks I like that story I have to
ask before we wrap up because I am a
Long Island native why Long Island and
did you actually shoot anything on Long
Island we did we shot one day in Long
Island we shoot the show in New Jersey
and we shot one day in Greenport we
wanted to pick a place that wasn't like
just small town because we'd sort of
done a small town show that just prior
to this but it felt like its own
community but was really close to a
major metropolitan area so it feels like
its own thing also I went to college
with a girl who was from the North Fork
she said oh it's the poor Fork that was
how she referred to it because it's not
South Hampton but I we looked at it
pictures I don't think god bless Google
Earth and it's like oh this seems really
specific and seems like something I
haven't seen a lot of these shows it's
like that you'll hear shooted in
Vancouver and a lot of the that's why a
lot of these shows look exactly the same
a lot of genre shows that shoot in Bank
were kind of look like the x-files I
look like what you expected so I like
that it has its own vibe I'm always all
for a long island getting love I can't
speak to the forked Sun from Nassau
County but it is a very special place
that I'm happy to see get some love on
TV thank you guys so much for your time
today to everybody out there watching
this interview if you like what you
heard right now guess what you could get
more emergent stalk we're gonna have a
button that you could click to watch
another interview on the show please
keep an eye out for it September 24th 10
9 central on ABC check it out another
thank you to the career right here guys
we have so much coverage from San Diego
comic-con 2019 coming your way real soon
so keep an eye on the channel